yolande s'excuser quand on se trouve sur
mister president et depuis ta leur show
sur cet écran d'accueil et je me demande
est ce que ce vigile n'est pas le frère
jumeau du président de la république
aille là moyens ya moyen bon allez c'est
parti vous allez vite comprendre le but
on est ce vigile et on doit se prendre
une balle à la place du président comme
ça et ça a l'air dur sans déconner ta
[ __ ] oil et c'est une balle de quelle
puissance qui se prend quoi calibre 70
millions aux cov
ok cette fois je pense qu'on va réussir
à d'autres au wat 5 passes c'est quoi
c'est vrai que mon gars elle tirera pas
profit de 6 watts info est ce que c'est
une manière de dire coucou je ne sais
pas puisque à ce tube dans le plus grand
des cannes tout le monde continue
d'applaudir ok très bien
bon à aller aux valeureux tenté mais sur
le président y est temps d monsieur le
président arrêtez de minutes quelqu'un
tente de monsieur le président quand
même pas vous vous inquiétez un vote
rouge il se fait exploser les tripes
devant vous ah bon tu avais essayé
monsieur le président reid qui font que
dans des jolis en gilet pare balles
je m'en vais je m'en bats les couilles
de mousser président moi gilet
pare-balles talus mais je pense qu'il ya
des niveaux
ok je m'en bats les steaks je suis en
train de faire l'amour à une chaise et
mais c'est super dur en plus on
déconnait faut vraiment y aller comme ça
et brad boyes watts à aller dans le
public le 3 4 ap le président reagan
poussette kaki qui ont cependant un film
d'action
violence du choc à ces niveaux suivants
wattao passé le président pose à désolé
bon si vous voulez voilà c'est pas grave
je me caresse les faits cependant vous
êtes en train de mourir il ya pas de
problème ah mais c'est super dur là
monsieur le président c'est lui et ça va
oui ça va là vous êtes d'abord annonce à
brax sabra personne ne voit cette table
est sur moi 1
je n'ai pas tenté de me sauver je n'ai
pas raté ok attendait ou là ou là le
vigile pourrait quoi vous monsieur le
président à une quelqu'un veut aboutir à
dessus maintenant tous j'ai perdu
attendez le mec il a fait une collatéral
quoi ya pas de problème deux points
allez sans souci ok cette fois c'est bon
allstate ammann a maintenant y est ok
y'a pas de problème
allez ouais j'aime bien que le président
me prends ce souverain comme ça pour
m'emmener aux toilettes c'est bien c'est
super bon président queille à puce à
l'oreille ok en fait si on passe entre
les deux teintes hamada hockey
écoutez nicotine se lever la foule plab
ça va monsieur le président tout va bien
aller monsieur le président vous êtes
vous je sais président n'était pas loin
de faire du breakdance bordel non je
voulais juste m'allonger sur l'echez
j'en fais un petit somme voilà comme ça
pas de problème bonsoir à tous
monsieur le président j'ai la même tête
que le président c'est bon c'est comme
si c'était moi
comment allez vous ça va au maire j'ai
rétrogradé what i phone
ah oui ok à cette chanson monsieur vous
auquel forme ou moins ok c'est ça le
tableau 1 chez moi bien à votre problème
ok spectacle michael jackson c'est comme
ça que le vigile fait un concert et un
problème quoi et chante dans le sol
ok on fait une feinte teinte à tana est
ridicule attention on passe par la
chaise mais non boîte
qu'est ce qu'il a lu en blanc je le
possède une telle cabale vous attaquer
aux à écouter son moonwalk y sent pas
les spectacles et c'est en quoi c'est le
président en tant que vous attaquez vous
êtes vivant à monsieur le tableau est
tombé sur nous monsieur vous sentez ma
main non non et non franchement à
l'ophite vous allez en fait je m'en bats
les steaks salut au revoir une figure
acrobatique incroyable après un repas
dans le monde le sont au dessus du
président ok on a permis jean-jacques le
cadreur merde c'est pas grave c'est
président voilà je vous mets ne m'en
fais tu as pas de problème y a pas de
complexe entre nous elle n'attend tatum
32 ans l'a mordu la mort n'est plus
petit au monde quoi elle ressemble
carrément professeur vous avez ce
président fort non c'est pas moi au
maire je me suis grillé on peut pas
s'asseoir tranquillement à côté comme ça
il ya un grand la dire sur lui qu'elle
devrait s'emballer state qui c'était
ridicule me mettais un mec qui voulait
marchander quoi
il a mangé un livre sa manière de
dédicacer un livre le président haut au
plus tard c'est ce qu'on appelle être au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment où
elle vit gilles pierre tu es mort il est
vivant il est beau
c'était mes 15 présage histoire faisant
rappelons se retrouvent vendredi soir
dans une nouvelle vidéo
et puis portez vous bien que de monde ce
qu'est ce que je suis en train de passer
l'aspirateur
je ne sais pas c'est que ça valide pas
sauter surtout l'iaa avait des garçons
allaient continuer